that's that's beautiful over-the-top  boogie grows hollis-jefferson out of the  way 16 point lead half it spells got it  way up there holiday off the bench and  in the bucket has hit it now holiday  going by levert who caught up  [Music]  holiday looking for another triple does  it again got four turnovers and it's  even in points off mistakes good pass  true holiday we'll flip it up at in  cousins got it  each one more tees it up pretty good  color the color monitor in my ear baylor  bears good pass Rondo AV corner welcome  Paul from beyond the arc he's down here  and and joining us at the Smoothie King  Center on for what happened last year  good take each walk 15 that lost the  third by 729 222 Rondo he's got holidays  space he wants another dime Waianae says  Tosca's eight overall in 2014 but the  Kings after his two years at Michigan